you
as soon as I personally picked up a
digital camera which was on an
assignment about the Grand Canyon I
realized it was incredible creative leap
for me that I could start to photograph
in the dark when I couldn't before
I didn't have to carry so much film I
could see my pictures immediately when I
was working on the digital universe
digital camera I took pictures with it
so I guess I took some of the first
digital pictures with a camera it was
quite big it was about oh let's say the
size of the toaster it weighed about
eight and a half pounds and if you saw
it it would be sort of a little rack of
boards electronic boards and then on top
of it will be a blue box that contained
the lens and the CCD this this new
technology has been just fabulous it's
been a rebirth imaging is not about
technology it's about it's about
pictures it's it's a very valuable thing
to have certainly things that I
photographed I think the impact that you
see in the images today's first of all
you get to see more images and you get
to see more casually snapped images
images are used now not just for
artistic sake but they're used to
supplement conversation I really believe
in the power of guitar changed things to
educate totally believe in the mission
of bachelor's Geographic but then
there's this great collection of history
there